one of the craziest things i've seen in
a long time is
well not too crazy because with tick
tock things
are
you know the world's different now
you had a record that came out in 2013
14 thinking with my dick yeah that
has just resurfaced you guys reworked it
to radio i saw you brought the guy out
um the dude with the cup and cause it
was it was a moment yeah superman we had
to live that moment together
yeah like uh how much like when you when
you reached out to that guy was he like
a fan fan or was he just like a fan of
that record because that was a that was
a that's my brother
that was a great moment man that's my
brother
we talking to dm all the time that's
funny and it's like
that's my brother we shared that moment
on stage together that we made history
they could never take that away from me
you know
what was uh your initial reaction to
having something like that go crazy on
tick tock because you know the tick tock
world is so different than the one i
don't really be on tick tock like i
don't know any i mean besides children i
don't know a lot of people i mean
it's so crazy i record videos and just
send them to
my people and they just put them on tick
tock
they do it for you yeah
you were kind of one of the first
artists that embraced
having a full-time videographer and
embraced documenting
[ __ ] on your youtube channel like
because
i didn't have a
platform so to say
i guess so i used to have to be not have
to but my way of connecting with people
was i used to make the lit clips on
instagram yes
this was before stories this is when you
only got like 15. yeah you got 15
seconds and it's it's a square yeah
those are the good old days